[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الولايات المتحده تكسر القوانين الدوليه
وترسل القاتل الصامت الى اوكرانيا وكيف
سيرد بوتين يستعد لمواجهه روسيا باربع مئه
وخمسين مليار دولار
غاضب جدا ويشتكي لكن الى من واردو يعيد
اطراف الحرب الاوكرانيه الى الطاوله من
جديد والكريم من يرحب واشنطن تحجز مقعدا
سريا على طاوله المفاوضات مع روسيا
والاسلحه البريطانيه ستعود لتضرب لندن بعد
الغنيمه الروسيه الاخيره وطباخ بوتين يثير
الغموض مره اخرى واللامن الروسي يجري
تحقيقاته ووزيره الخزانه الامريكيه في
الصين في مهمه صعبه لنزع فتيل للتوتر
وفرنسا تشعل غضب الجزائر وترفض طلبا
جزائريا في غايه الاهميه
النيتو يعلن عن المواجهه
الخصام يفوق التوقعات يخرج ما في جعبته
خوفا من الخطر الروسي او هكذا يقولها
اعضاء الحلف وها هو الامين العام لحلف
النيتو
يؤكد بان الحلفاء الاوروبيين وكندا
سيستثمرون في الانفاق الدفاعي 450 مليار
دولار اكثر مما تم الاتفاق عليه في عام
2014 حيث تمت زياده الانفاق الدفاعي بنسبه
اثنين بالمئه من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
سنويا وفق تعبيره مضيفا بان روسيا واحده
من التهديدات الرئيسيه لحلف النيتو
حديثه بقوله انه بعد ان اتفقوا على دعم
اوكرانيا على المدى الطويل فان الاعضاء
يؤيدون انضمامها في المستقبل بانتظار الرد
الروسي قصه انضمام اوكرانيا هي اشبه بقصه
ذاك المراهق الذي يقطع الوعود لمعشوقته
بان نهايه ذلك الحب الزواج وفي النهايه
يتزوج بصديقتها ونقصد انضمام فنلندا للحلف
وترك اوكرانيا
لنكمل وهنا غاضب جدا وذلك بعد ان قال له
الرئيس
البلغاريا لا اريد تزويدك بالاسلحه لان
هذا تصعيد والافضل لك ان تبحث عن حل سلمي
ليطلق زلنسكي شكواه للغرب وذلك بسبب
الاسلحه الروسيه بعيده المدى ويطالب الغرب
بمثلها لانها هي التي تعيق الهجوم
الاوكراني ليضرب رئيس الوزراء التشيكي
[موسيقى]
ستزود كييف بمروحيات قتاليه وذخيره واما
الولايات المتحده فخالفت التوقعات هذه
المره حيث افادت صحيفه واشنطن بان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن وفق على امداد اوكرانيا
بالذخائر عنقوديه وكان البنتاجون اعلن انه
س من هذه القنابل في اطار حزمه مساعدات
عسكريه جديده بقيمه 800 مليون دولار لدعم
جهود كييف للتصدي للعمليات العسكريه
الروسيه مثلت الذخائر العنقوديه مشكله
ملحه طيله عقود وتعرف بالقاتل الصامت وفقا
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر لكن الصحيفه
اشارت الى ان خطوه البيت الابيض تخالف
القانون الامريكي الذي يحضر استخدامه او
نقل الذخائر العنقوديه فيا لها من خطوه
امريكيه خطيره قد تجر العالم الى حرب
عالميه لا تبقي ولا تذر ليقولها صريحه هذه
المره بان بعض الاعضاء في النيتو لا
يؤيدون عضويه اوكرانيا لانهم خائفون من
روسيا بحسب وكاله تازه فهل يرد اعضاء
النيتو ام سيتجاهلون تصريحاته كما تجالوا
طلبه للاسلحه
على الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان للتدخل
مره اخرى حيث يستقبل نظيره الاوكراني في
انقره وهي المره الاولى للزالينسكي التي
يزور بها تركيا منذ اندلاع الحرب في بلاده
وافادت قناه خبر التركيه بان الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان قد يلتقي بعد محادثته مع
الرئيس الاوكراني بنظيره الروسي ولاديمير
بوتين لمناقشه المزيد من الخطوات لحل
الازمه الاوكرانيه فهل يفعلها اردوغان هذه
المره يجيب المتحدث باسم
بان موسكو تتابع عن كتب المحادثات بين
الرئيسين التركي والاوكراني وان الكرملين
مهتم بمعرفه ما ستتم مناقشته لكن مهلا
مهلا فهناك مشارك اخر على طاوله المفاوضات
مع روسيا انها الولايات المتحده حيث كشفت
قناه ام بي سي نيوز الامريكيه عن لقاءات
سريه بين مسؤولين امريكيين سابقين
ودبلوماسيين روس مقربين من الكرملين بينهم
وزير الخارجيه
بهدف وقف الحرب في اوكرانيا بل اقتنعت
واشنطن اخيرا بان حل سوى التفاوض مع الدب
الروسي ومن معارك المفاوضات نعود الى
الحرب الاوكرانيه وهنا غنيمه بريطانيه
تحصل عليها موسكو حيث نجح جنود الجيش
الروسي في تنفيذ عمليه نقل صاروخ ستوم
شادو البريطاني الى موسكو بحسب صحيفه
هندستانتاينز لتضيف الصحيفه بان حصول
موسكو على الصاروخ البريطاني انتصار كبير
لروسيا نعم هو انتصار للروس لان حصولهم
عليه خطير جدا وذلك لانهم سيرسلونه لمجمع
التسليح لتبكيكي ومعرفه اجزاء التصنيع كي
يتم صنع نسخه لصواريخ مماثله له اي ان
بضاعتكم ردت الي يا احفاد اليزابيث من
جهته اكد المتحدث باسم قياده العمليات
الشرقيه الاوكرانيه
ان القوات الاوكرانيه احرز التقدما على
الاطراف الشماليه لبخمه وكذلك الجنوبيه في
منطقه
وتقدمت مسافه اكثر من كيلو متر خلال اليوم
الماضي هل الكيلومتر واحد يعتبر انجازا
بنظركم ياليته كان كيلو بطاطا كنا على
الاقل اكلنا نحن والمشتركين البطاطس
استمتعنا بمشاهده هذا الفيديو لننتقل الى
معارك الغموض في روسيا هنا يعود غموض
كالعاده بعد اقتحام الامن الروسي لمنزله
والعثور على شعر مستعار واسلحه ومبالغ
كبيره من المال وجوازات سفر تحمل العديد
من الاسماء المستعره لبريغوجين بالعديد من
الدول عاده التحقيقات مجددا بسبب مقتنيات
يتساءل الجميع عن مكان اقامه الطباخ بوتين
فتاتي الاجابه من الرئيس البيلاروسي
الكسندر لوكاشينكو بقوله من قائد مجموعه
فاجن ليس في بيلاروسيا مشيرا الى انه
موجود في مدينه
الروسيه من امر غريب ومحير لماذا ما يزال
في روسيا هل سيتم معاقبته ام ان بوتين لا
يزال يخبئ شيئا سيصدم العالم به الامر
محير وبين هذا وذاك اعلنت سلطات مدينه
اوليانو فيسكا الروسيه اعتقال مواطن مصري
بتهمه تدنيس نسخه من القران الكريم على
نشر مقطع فيديو يوثق افعاله على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي برايكم هل اصبح الروس
خط الدفاع الاول عن القران الكريم
الاحداث والتطورات هنا الجرح الجزائري
ورغم مرور قرابه 60 عاما على استقلال
الجزائر بعد الاحتلال الفرنسي يظل ملف
التجارب النوويه من اهم النقاط الخلافيه
بين حكومتي باريس والجزائر خصوصا ان
معاناه سكان المناطق التي احتضنت هذه
التجارب ما زالت قائمه حتى يومنا هذا
لتخرج التقارير مجددا مؤكده ان فرنسا رفضت
تسليم الجزائر خرائط التفجيرات النوويه
التي اجرتها باريس في الصحراء الجزائريه
بدايه من عام
1958 الى غايه
1966 للمساعده في تحديد مناطق اثار
الاشعاعات النوويه وتطهيرها بعد فشل
العديد من المسؤولين الامريكان من قبلها
وصلت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه جانتي الى
الصين لتعلن انه من مصلحه كلا البلدين
الابقاء على خطوط اتصال مباشره واضحه على
المستويات الاقتصاديه الرفيعه ليرد رئيس
الوزراء الصيني بان تمت تحسن في العلاقات
مع واشنطن
[موسيقى]